ich esse heute auf der gesamten Welt
zumindest verspricht das eine
Restaurantkette bei der wir heute
einkehren werden wir haben das
Restaurant wie heute so oft auf tiktok
gefunden wie sollte es anders sein und
es ist einiges anders als sonst das ist
nämlich ein All you can eat Restaurant
ganz anders als alles was wir kennen auf
diesem Kanal und ich sag mal so dass es
in einem Restaurant speisen aus der
gesamten Welt gibt
kann nicht nur positiv sein aber wir
finden es heraus gucken wir uns
gemeinsam mal das Restaurant an herzlich
willkommen Masons taste the world
Saarbrücken Trier Kaiserslautern wir
sind nach Trier gefahren das war für uns
am nächsten und hier steht direkt
meistens ist wirklich das kulinarische
Abenteuer die Welt kennenzulernen das
ist das gesamte Konzept an einem Ort die
ganze Welt kulinarisch kennenlernen das
ist ein Stück weit das was ich mir zur
Aufgabe gemacht habe auf dem Kanal
wirklich verschiedene Geschmäcker
verschiedene Küchen kennenzulernen
selbst zu erleben euch näher zu bringen
deshalb klingt das sehr sehr schön und
das Besondere ist wenn wir meinen die
Bewertung schauen dann sehen wir 4,7
Sterne was ja schon mal super ist aus
1854 Bewertung und spätestens da war ich
okay ich muss dahin ich muss das
Austesten weil das klingt so gut um wahr
zu sein das ist ja wirklich die Lösung
aller Probleme so wenn ich mit der
großen Freundesgruppe wäre ich würde nur
noch da essen gehen der eine schreibt
das Essen war wirklich super der andere
freundlicher Service noch einer
Preis-Leistungsverhältnis ist bestens
sehr gutes Konzept leckeres Essen aber
einzelne schreiben auch ich verstehe den
Hype um diese Lokalität nicht dieses
Konzept mit so guten Bewertungen klingt
einfach zu gut und wahr zu sein und
deshalb habe ich einfach selbst getestet
[Musik]
hier sind wir nun also wir sitzen am
Platz ist noch relativ leer weil der
Laden gerade erst aufgemacht hat wir
wurden schon mal eingewiesen haben das
ganze erklärt bekommen und das ist
wirklich ein wildes Konzept also wir
haben hier ein Tablet das kennt man ja
so von so Audi can eat Geschichten und
wir haben fünf verschiedene Kontinente
vereinfacht also sie haben Amerika z.B
äh Europa Afrika bzw Orient Asien und
Australien und wir können uns jetzt
innerhalb von zwei Stunden durch die
ganze Welt bestellen also ich finde das
Konzept wirklich sehr interessant aber
auch sehr ambitioniert muss ich sagen
weil um ehrlich zu sein so das ist
eigentlich so ein für mich so ein Reflex
oder wenn man so bei einem Restaurant so
fünf verschiedene Küchen bestellen kann
und hier kann man nicht 5 sondern Küchen
von fünf verschiedenen Kontinenten
bestellen ich finde gerade so wenn man
mit mehreren Leuten ist kennst du ich
will heute zum Asiaten ich will heute
zum Italiener perfekt sein dafür kann es
perfekt sein alles ist auf jeden Fall
schon eine ganz andere Sache irgendwie
auch auf unserem Channel also ich habe
noch nie was bald
gemacht so das ist schon es wird heute
anders das wird spannend auf jeden Fall
aber grundsätzlich ist das ja eine Sache
die ich voll befürworte neue Dinge
auszuprobieren jetzt gucken wir mal was
wir uns als allererstes nehmen eine
Sache ist mir direkt in die Augen
gestoßen
bei Amerika zack brauche ich einmal gibt
keine andere Möglichkeit dann nämlich
das wäre krass wenn wenn wie gut sind
wenn die gut sind dicker das sind
gefühlt direkt zwei Sachen wo ich sagen
würde dass es echt schwer ist das gut zu
machen deshalb lass uns abschicken wir
sind heute knallhart bestellen wir zack
sechs Minuten laufen ab in der Zeit
kommt dann auf unser Essen ich bin sehr
gespannt los geht's die ersten zwei
Speisen sind angekommen wir befinden uns
ja in Amerika genau genommen in
Südamerika wir haben mexikanische also
Maiskolben die sehen schon das ganze das
ist eher so ein bisschen so ne so ein
kleines Snack so was aber auch cool ist
weil wir wollen ja so viel Probieren
irgendwie geht oh wir müssen auch neue
bestellen ja er
kriegt dann direkt da wird nervös die
Kamera wackelt gleich vom Konzept her
richtig geil dass man so Snack sizes hat
dass man sich wirklich durchprobieren
kann und der Case Attacke sieht auch
official aus möchte ich sagen deshalb
kommt erstmal
also schmeckt übelst gut weil ich habe
auch richtig Hunger also ja genauso
deshalb bin ich sehr lecker
was sagst du ich weiß komplett was du
meinst es macht schon vieles richtig so
Konsistenz Tortilla Käse Fleisch ist
nice aber das Gewürz ist halt so das
komplette 100 % Akku ja ja so wäre das
mag und ich mag das auch so jetzt weiß
man halt sowas auch möglich ist das ist
aber auch das was ich ein Stück bei der
Party habe heute alleine wenn man sich
zum Beispiel so eine echte
napolitanische Pizza angucken was wir
auch schon auf dem Kanal gemacht haben
wie viel Zeit da rein geflossen ist
sowas zu meistern ne so und das ist ja
das was wir ansetzen so bei jedem
Gericht und wenn man dann halt 40
verschiedene auf der Karte hat dann kann
nichts imperfekter Ausführung sein
eigentlich sonst kann nicht sein aber
das was ich jetzt so gesehen habe
gefällt mir eigentlich schon echt gut
ich probiere hier
einfach alles ehrlich bewerten für mich
war der Tag kurz zum Beispiel der sieben
von zehn
muss ich sagen ich habe noch nie gute in
Deutschland vergessen
bei dem Zickzack Video bei uns ja auch
sechs von zehn oder waren auch andere
Sachen 10%
weißt du was das ist das ist besten
wahrscheinlich mit Rotwein und so habe
ich auch noch nie gegessen das ist aber
auch auf sowas wie eine
Rösti oder sowas auch interessant sieht
gut aus aber
ultra zart ultra intensiv auch also das
wirklich leute Leute
die Currysauce ist so ein bisschen
blumig und echt scharf ein bisschen
scharf ja aber finde ich auch lecker
die nächsten zwei Sachen sind angekommen
wir haben einen Banden wie Brioche
Burger dürfte Vietnam sein oder ja und
orasko Brasilien dazu haben wir
Chimichurri und vielleicht sowas wie so
eine Paprika
tschüss
aber trotzdem 8 von 10 ich würde ich bin
G8 von 10 mit dann zu rasco also man
muss auch sagen es geht so unfassbar
schnell also das Essen kommt wirklich am
laufenden Band
also ja wenn man so weiß was gutes für
rasco ist bisschen under waving 6 von 10
hier haben wir jetzt die australische
Bacon rollt mich auch ein bisschen Frage
ist das so typisch aber was man wirklich
sagen muss diese ganzen kleinen Sachen
oder was ja danke schön die ganzen
Kleinigkeiten die wir so einen Tisch
bekommen sind alle sind so hübsche
angerichtet so schönen Teller hier das
ist wirklich
so Hackfleisch Käsefüllung und dazu
Chips so Chip crumble haben die
Australien und Deutsch ist das euer
Lieblingsessen wir probieren einmal für
euch der Restaurantbesuch kostet hier
unter der Woche all you can eat
natürlich 30,90 €. also nur für jeden
und dass er damit anfangen kann
wirklich was hat schon so es hat
irgendwie auch so eine süße fast so von
so einer Datteln im Speckmantel noch mit
Honig irgendwie drüber Pinseln oder so
aber es ist pervers Endstufe ja also das
ist halt so fett mit Fett und Fett
Klassiker schmeckt Fett
was gibst du 7 mal
auch wieder lecker auch nichts
Besonderes 2 afrikanischen Klassiker
Salat also es ist natürlich also viel
viel Zauberer also Halloumi gibt's
eigentlich auch in jedem Restaurant
mittlerweile aber ich bin gespannt
zwei Stunden geile Würzung schön
angegrillt ist echt lecker so ich glaube
so langsam aber sicher zeichnet sich so
der rote Farbe ab es ist eigentlich so
ich glaube gerade Leute die wirklich
Bock haben die noch nicht viel gegessen
haben sich ausprobieren wollen kommen
hier voll auf ihre Kosten weil alles ist
so ein bisschen germanisiert so weißt du
weil nichts ist so in der harten
authentischen original ausführen weil es
wahrscheinlich auch von der
Infrastruktur gar nicht möglich wäre
aber alles schmeckt gut man kann ganz
viel ausprobieren es macht Spaß die eine
oder andere Sache überzeugt dann doch
schon wieder also das sieht schon echt
spitze aus was haben wir hier können Sie
natürlich auch wieder amerikanisch sein
ist aber dem afrikanischen Kontinent
zugeordnet ich probiere sieht echt top
aus
sieht besser aus als es schmeckt sei
ganz ehrlich ja jetzt nicht typisch
afrikanisch macht optisch sehr viel her
ist aber nicht mein Favorit sechs von
zehn schwarzes Bann ist eben für mich
immer nur Schnickschnack ja ja wir
hatten so Optik ich bin glaube ich ein
guter Kunde für jemanden Restaurant
betreibt weil irgendwie Essen nicht über
Hunger geht nicht bei mir anders und wir
sind beim letzten Kontinent angekommen
in Asien wir haben uns zwei Gerichte
rausgekriegt einmal ein grünes Teig
Curry mit chicken und einmal satay
Hähnchen ausprobiert als erstes Mal
Sattel Hähnchen schmeckt lecker Satire
so schmeckt nach jesuse 75 %.
also ich kann wirklich nicht mehr werden
so ist es halt eine Gabel mit allem
schön scharf wirklich schön scharf
typischer Thai Curry Geschmack und das
sage ich nachdem wir letztens ein Tag
essen in Thailand gemacht haben also
schmeckt schon echt nicht verkehrt wir
haben jetzt noch zwei Desserts und ich
sage euch ehrlich danach bin ich bedient
ich kann dann auch nicht mehr
Kaiserschmarrn sieht gut aus das
probiere
boah geil Kaiser lecker
also eins bin ich auf jeden Fall und das
ist satt aber sollte man bei einem All
you can eat Restaurant ja auch sein ich
bin auch lecker satt geworden also das
habe ich ja die ganze Zeit gesagt das
sind wirklich leckere Speisen aber und
das ist das große aber geht nicht zu
diesem Restaurant es ist alles einmal
und denkt euch okay jetzt weiß ich wie
alles schmeckt nein also es gibt
natürlich noch viel viel mehr über diese
dort abgebildeten Gerichte hinaus
eigentlich nichts war in einer wirklich
authentischen Zubereitungsart sondern
das war einfach immer so an den
deutschen Markt angepasst mit dem
Zutaten und Gewürzen die man hier
einfach bekommt und das ist ja auch
irgendwo klar ich meine das ist ein All
you can eat Konzept müssen auch
wirtschaftlich sein müssen auch Rechnung
bezahlen und wirklich alles perfekt zu
machen ist einfach nicht möglich oder
vollkommen unwirtschaftlich schreibt man
in die Kommentare was ihr von dem
Restaurant Konzept haltet wenn ihr aber
noch weitere Vorschläge habt für coole
Restaurants wo wir vorbeischauen sollten
schreibt sie in die Kommentare schickt
mir eine Insider die App sehen uns beim
nächsten Video wieder macht's gut bis
dahin genau